they may have only appeared once but
they still left an impression
I do love my doctor who lists and I
ranked the Doctor Who companions a while
back and now I want to rank what I'm
gonna call the doctor who one time
companions now my mind the definition of
a companion to someone who has actually
travelled in the TARDIS and some of the
people I'm going to talk about having
but the people who are eligible for this
are people who appeared in only one
story a quick reminder on my part two
partners count as one story so I'm
giving my listing for the top ten
characters who only made one appearance
but I still loved them number 10 Boers
you know there was a fair chance that he
would have ranked higher if he hadn't
turned out to be a Dalek shell thing
because I really liked this guy I loved
his rapport with the doctor I loved that
I always liked the idea of these people
sort of out of time I mean none of us
can really keep up with the doctor but
someone from an era who you would think
there's no way they can keep up with the
doctor but they'd he's got this
easygoing rapport with them and for
crayola he goes dude when the doctor
shows up writing a tank and playing a
guitar that's just a great reaction I
love the personality I loved his rapport
and I had secretly hoped that he would
have been the next companion you know
until you know Dalek shell thing we
found that out but I still love this guy
number nine lady Christina de Souza she
really was designed very deliberately to
be a character that we wished would
stick around and that we wish would
travel with the doctor but never happens
it's very deliberate that she is the
great companion that could have been and
I would actually say that they maybe
play that up just a touch too much but
again I really like her rapport with the
doctor I like how easygoing and how well
she rolls with everything going on and
she's just got a magnetic personality
number eight Agatha Christie I have
mixed feelings about the actual episode
the unicorn and the wasps but Agatha
Christie as a character lover I loved
the performance as she really sells the
intelligence of the character and it's
interesting watching a character who is
very
clearly very smart but still is having a
hard time wrapping their head around
what the doctor sort of exposes them to
now usually when you have an intelligent
character confronted with the doctor and
the things that come with the doctor
they tend to just go no this can't be
true but I like that you know she has
that to a certain extent but then she
just uses her head and observes and goes
with what's going on because she breaks
it down and picks it apart and she's not
just stubborn and pigheaded which is
what usually happens with supposedly
intelligent people who encounter the
doctor number seven Santa Claus now this
is really one comes down to the
performance Nick Frost is Santa Claus
he's just wonderful he's warm he's
affable he just ever so slightly
mysterious now is this a cheat
considering that at the end of the
episode we find out he's probably not
real and he's just a dream construct
thing you know what I don't care I
thought he was funny the way he came in
and just the way he just treats
everything just so matter-of-fact that
yeah
I'm Santa yeah I got elves a reindeer
what number six Sally Sparrow
effectively really the Nancy Drew of the
Doctor Who universe Sally Sparrow is
wonderfully performed and she's another
one who's a very intelligent character
but she's not an O at all she doesn't
just understand everything off the top
of her head but she she works the
problem she's dealing with something
that's strange and odd and mysterious
and she's got to tackle it one bit at a
time too in order to come to grips with
it and to wrap her head around it and I
love her determination like when she's
arguing with the doctor over the the TV
conversation where she faces just
demands of him look just try and explain
it try me come on number five Joan
Redfern I know that Jessica Hynes made
another appearance but that was as the
characters granddaughter or maybe it was
even great-granddaughter I can't
remember so you know what I'm not
counting that as a reoccurrence and
she's the nother one who it's just it's
funny how much I really came to enjoy
her as a character because I mean you
know the doctor very much himself is a
character out of time he really doesn't
have a
next time that he belongs to and he
tends to gravitate towards people who
are intelligent ahead of the era that
they live in now not to say that Joan
isn't intelligent at all she certainly
is but she's very much of the time in
which she exists no she's not a woman
ahead of her time she's a woman of her
time and that's actually not something
that we always see you in dr. who
certainly not from characters who were
meant to like and appreciate usually
those are the ones who are the obstacles
and her chemistry and rapport with David
Tennant they built a really believable
very lovely romance and you could see
the sadness in her when he came back as
the doctor and he wasn't John Smith
anymore just how you could feel how much
she missed him she was a great character
and a great story
number four Adelaide Brooke this very
easily could have just been the generic
no-nonsense commander and to a certain
extent she is that but she's got a heart
and you can see it in these little slice
smiles sometimes or when you realize
that her determination is very much
rooted in caring about these people even
the ones that she bosses around Jesus
she's doing it because it's what is best
for them and it's what's gonna keep them
safe and get them home or it's supposed
to and there's just something about the
weight and the depth of her delivery
when she's relaying that story about
seeing the Daleks as a child she really
sells that so well and she's just got
this incredibly firm sense this
wonderful moral grounding more so than
the doctor in this particular episode
which you know is why it ends the way
that it does she's a character who
challenges the doctor very directly
not too many companions do that
certainly not one timers number three
Madame de Pompadour this largely comes
down to chemistry I love her chemistry
and rapport with David Tennant and she's
fun and she's flirty and she's
intelligent she's philosophical she's
introspective she's adventurous to the
extent that the light that she leaves
allows her to be and again a bit like
Joan Redfern very much a product of her
time and the and the her station in life
but still
able to just sort of step up to the
doctor and meet him on his own terms
number two Jackson Lake again like some
of the other ones I've talked about this
is an episode that I have I'm up and
down on it's okay but I really do like
him I like and I like him even better
once he realizes he's not actually the
doctor and instead of and he has served
that instant moment of yo his braver
kind of melts away but then he sees his
child and even though he knows he can't
save him he knows the doctor is there
and he's gonna do everything that he can
to help and then at the end he's still
gonna let that experience of having very
briefly lived the doctor's life inform
just his excitement and his reaction of
being inside the TARDIS and them running
out going that's enough that's enough
like it's not he knew that he couldn't
handle it but he still sort of came in
and go I just I touched something that
is incredible and amazing and I can't
live that but I'm so happy I touched it
the character he's this incredible
balance of adventure and reaching for
the stars but but still knowing that he
should not be among them is this really
way balanced that this character strikes
and I really love it
who comes in at number one this is
probably gonna strike people as an odd
choice and I'm gonna have a hard time
explaining why I love this so much but
here goes anyway the bad wolf entity now
I suppose you can make the argument that
this isn't really a one-timer but in my
mind it actually had a physical body and
presence only once that was in day the
doctor when it took on the form of Rose
Tyler now I've talked about Rosado
before when I did conveyance and I liked
Rose fine I don't love her but there's
something about this performance from
Billie Piper bringing you just enough of
roses spunk and life and giving it just
this slight air of mystery the slight
air of I don't know if we can trust this
thing and I don't know if I can really
explain it it's just something about
that idea of it taking her form and the
way she plays that it's just in
sure as me I am mesmerized by her when
she is on the screen playing this part
way more so than I ever was with rose
and as a result the bad wolf entity is
my personal pick for my favorite
one-time Doctor Who companion so that's
my list what about yours do you think I
was completely nuts would you reorder
these is your list completely different
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
please go ahead like subscribe check out
the council of geeks podcast on iTunes
and stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned